but back to Ryan's question what are the
loops that might be a different
conversation on another day off camera
so there are loopholes ask a corrupted
expert
[Music]
you guys ever heard of a non-profit
called feeding our future yeah yeah you
like it you big fan don't do that to me
what I know where you're going you're
[ __ ] set me up for sure dude I don't
know I'll be honest I don't know
anything about it Ryan's curveball
Master hold on this is a non-profit
coveted relief food program for kids and
you think there's some kind of trap I
didn't say that you're also still
setting me up no dude I just heard of
them I can't believe that I can't
believe you think that it's not that
whole yeah can what why are you passing
it on exactly your Feng shui's off well
I'm not liking your feng shui recent
news this non-profit that was meant to
uh you know bring relief to the children
and then the knee Anthony recently
caught committing 250 million dollars of
fraud using government money every time
dude I told you guys to pay attention to
this problem I've been on them since the
beginning is that a thing like so many
big charity things are just always like
because the money's too good dude like
why I just that's what Joe does all the
time right here's something for the
first time
yeah here's it for the first time what
have you saw this right
right I just think it's just too easy to
get money these days I mean especially
during covert people just handing out
free or the government was handing out
free money like the PPP frauds everyone
was here yeah damn and ATD was nice
though like a lot
yeah this group uh I mean 47 of them are
being uh charged damn shoot so that
ain't like one guy in the company was
doing a little sneaky sneaky it's like
the whole thing was formed for this
reason they're all in on it though yeah
what was the total 250 million oh bro
how do they even get in a position to
like start it
you know what I'm saying they take
advantage of events like current events
like covid hurricanes probably you know
yeah and then they just like start
asking people for money yeah it's like
hey we'll send this to Ukraine or
something and then I mean that's a good
one yeah oh yeah dude [ __ ] happens all
the time in the world you could just
easily make a non-profit remember Coney
remember that one
yeah can oh what you don't remember
Coney he was the uh I mean Nigerian uh
was he Nigerian the prince all I know is
the uh uh gun or something machine
machine gun preacher had to do with
Coney Gerard Butler that movie that was
about corny well yeah Connie was another
thing but every time there's a natural
disaster anytime there's a terrorist we
all want to kill yeah then you see the
non-profits pop up and they all go
donate money for me to take care of this
for you and there's a thing with
non-profits that 100 of it doesn't need
to necessarily move out of the prompt
nonprofit it could stay in there and
they can pay themselves but this case is
a lot different because you're not
giving your money to them in at least
not directly to 200. your taxes are
going to the government and the
government's giving that out to these
different programs and this one managed
to get 250 million from the government
the government right so yes it wasn't
like us giving up they defrauded the
government yeah oh oh that's not good so
like
did they ever do anything actual that
was good yeah they might have gave a kid
a I'm sure they had to help yeah they
made one video I'm sure they helped
themselves out a lot more along the way
I mean you really just have to do enough
for the photos right for evidence that
you are doing it photo ops I don't know
I wonder how much they actually have to
do to where they can be like look we
still did do stuff you know what I'm
saying well here's a list of some things
they did they purchased luxury Vehicles
oh they funded international travel but
residential and Commercial Real Estate
in Minnesota Ohio Kentucky Kenya and
turkey and well they have to store the
food they have to deliver the food and
the nice cars yeah the logistics makes
sense so far yeah if it's not on a bench
you guys know how the kids are I'm not
gonna eat those Lunchables see this is
this is one of those moments where it'd
be good to be like one of those Nations
where um
the government can't be embarrassed by
things like this so they have to
retaliate in full you know what I'm
talking about it's like it's like like
China or some [ __ ] right it's like you
take advantage of the government in some
way they gotta they gotta you can't be
embarrassed right you can't be like oh
my God what are you gonna do you know
like they they did this to you you know
great so you want that burger yeah
essentially yeah
or sent to a prison camp I mean it's
like every corporation you have to
compromise the existence of your
department like you have to prove why
your department is worth the funding
yeah and if you're not bringing results
of some kind I mean this is the person
in government approving these things
then you know who's the one doing the
research capable of sending like 10 or
50 million dollars at a time to an
organization without having full
understanding and knowledge of what
they're sending off dude they get in
trouble too well that's the opportunity
that you're seizing when there's a
crisis or an emergency as things get
processed quicker like what happened
with covid is money was moving faster
than people could check it and that's
why they come after you lay later after
you've done all these covered frauds and
everything with all the assistants
slowly but surely every person that
cheated the system would lied about what
they were doing or how many employees
they had or how many you know people you
were paying for whatever reason yeah
they're gonna come for their money I
think oh for sure IRS always shows up
eventually right it just took them a
little while they figured it out though
yeah they're coming after you 250
million is a lot how much is left
of that 250 million yeah you can't get
all that back I feel like people are
done like you start buying all that
stuff obviously someone's gonna figure
out something's fishy
Logistics bro it makes sense if they got
to get the food to the children how do
you get a refund on Kenyan land
but yeah it wasn't just it was like uh
so they're charged with conspiracy wire
fraud money laundering so there's a
whole of course this process isn't just
I have 250 million every step along the
way is illegal so those are all in the
charges right I wonder how much more
money they got that wasn't like
accounted for right because he never you
can always no when you're doing illegal
[ __ ] like this at this level you're
hiding a pretty good amount I'm sure
you've seen Ozarks open up a casino
you're not gonna go down with all your
cash if it makes you think twice about
like supporting like those things on
Instagram where it says oh donating it's
like 100 things they have a site where
they show exactly how much uh of your
money that or or how much money that
they make for each non-profit is spent
on the actual cause I think there's like
I think all the of non-profits have to
report all of their income onto a
website so you get to see like all of
their financials were they doing that
but like the categorization of those
financials are very obscure right they
probably reported it wrong like I too
myself on my own personal LLC sometimes
and making careful careful guys guys I'm
very careful allegedly allegedly right
but like uh it's the difference between
um buying a coffee when you're having a
coffee for a work meeting versus buying
a coffee because you're tired and you
just need a coffee and you put on the
car you're obscuring the categorization
of those purchases right so the same
thing I might get a Bentley because the
office needs a car for my Transportation
but you know what I'm saying so I've
never done that ever so yeah me neither
I'm just saying I've seen this in the
Ozarks
I feel like I see this a lot too with
GoFundMe like where people are making
like fake gofundme's and [ __ ] oh that
for sure happened that was happening
with those oh my God the Asian hate
chicks or whatever there's so many fake
GoFundMe I just remember that one with
that guy like it was like the the three
they like set it up towards he was like
homeless but he gave 20 bucks to them
for gas he ran out of gas homeless guy
gave her the money they made a whole
then they actually all like knew each
other and [ __ ] but they got all the land
from the beginning yeah the guy really
was homeless too yeah and then yeah they
all got arrested for it because the
couple actually ended up not giving him
money so then he ratted everybody out
they didn't give him no that's like the
definition of just greed and like so
many different levels yeah not caring
about other people's money and stuff
because like the money that they worked
hard on but it's like these guys found
like a cheat code so they're just like
I'm just gonna do that when you were uh
learning real estate and you were like
in in classes and in school did any
teacher ever be like but here's a little
loophole Kevin
you didn't hear from me
but you never you always learn how to do
things the right way right uh I mean
dude
learning real estate and getting your
license and then learning real estate
are like two completely different things
I mean the books and what you need to
pass your tests is a complete opposite
because that's just kind of like the
fundamentals of what happens in a
transaction when you become a real
estate agent or broker owner I mean you
got to understand the business aspect
right which is completely different from
what the books are because the books
don't teach you business right right
books aren't going to teach you
accounting books aren't going to teach
you how to even find business yeah so
there's all that that comes into play
which is it just teaches you how to not
screw up when you are oh even that I
mean one out of six people I have a
license in California so it's not that
hard
there's more Realtors than there are
homes for sale in California and that
could be possible I would not doubt that
wow back to Ryan's question what are the
loops
and how do I not do them
that might be a different conversation
on another day
off camera so there are loopholes ask a
corrupted expert
I could put a mask over here yeah so for
non-profit a voice changer say the same
Blazer you don't necessarily need
qualifications to start a non-profit or
be a person that runs a non-profit right
you don't go to school
you still have to apply and be you know
get the official 501c3 and like have
your organization like documented in a
certain way you know what I mean you
gotta do that stuff but after that but
that's like DMV basically right there I
think that's just paperwork yeah that's
just like setting up your corporation
hiring someone to do it e or S Corp or
whatever I think that's the same exact
thing yeah yeah I think so non-profits
to me are the scariest thing to watch
out for because uh they're like it
almost seems like they're in the thick
of so many things that are more morally
good that you really don't see it and
you can be guilted into uh you know
getting conned dude I get guilted in
donating money all the time I do at like
grocery stores when it's like donate a
dollar or round up yeah I'll do that oh
the Roundup for Saint Jude yeah that's
nice biggest scam out there I know
people that
well remember the Red Cross was under
pretty big scrutiny too you for a little
bit yeah and that's like the main
default non-profit in my brain or
Salvation Army was it because they only
gave like [ __ ] like five percent to
where it actually goes and the rest is
supposed to stop American request is a
for-profit company but that does like
charitable work and stuff I think it
might be different but giving a
percentage to the actual cause is still
standard they don't have to give
everything you give that's like not
required let's start a non-profit y'all
well in a way JK isn't non-profit
[Music]
foreign